Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and if you've seen
Wonder Woman, you probably noticed the
new DC movie intro featuring the members
of the Justice League plus a ton of
missable characters from DC Comics. And
what's really cool about this is, this is
Warner Brothers and DC cinematic saying
'Yo, we have a ton of amazing characters
in our comic book universe and we're
bringing them all into our movies at
some point, so hold on to your butts!'
So in this video, I'm going to go through
this intro and identify all the
characters that I noticed and explain
how they might play into the movies
currently on DC's schedule, or movies that
are still in development or just rumored,
or in my own wild boy (wild boy?) wild fanboy
fantasies. So, one big thing to point out
at the top during this montage, that
actually kind of parallels the Justice
League animated series intro - yeah guys,
Green Lantern, Hal Jordan, is part of this.
So, this is a big deal. When Warner
Brothers announced the Justice League
movie and released that poster, a lot of
people were wondering why Green Lantern
wasn't part of this. I mean, maybe they
figured people are still recovering from
the 2011 Ryan Reynolds version, I mean I
know it's still a sore subject for Ryan
Reynolds. "Please don't make the supersuit
green. Or animated!" Meanwhile, others were
asking where is Martian Manhunter - who
along with Green Lantern was also part
of the original Justice League lineup. I
mean... not that many people were asking
about Martian Manhunter, but, yeah, you
know... some were. Anyway, it doesn't matter
because now this whole DC family is back
in this new intro. So let's comb through
this big lineup and point out who
everyone is, at least the ones that I can
make out. Okay, so in the center we have
the main DC Trinity: Superman, Batman and
Wonder Woman, flanked by the rest of the
Justice League:
Aquaman, Flash and Cyborg. This is the
Justice League that will be in the
upcoming Justice League movie in
December. And if you look closely, the
proximity of nearby characters might be
a hint that we could see those people
make cameos in Justice League as well. So,
soaring over them is Hal Jordan -
Green Lantern, and standing to the right
of Aquaman is John Stewart - Green Lantern.
For those who don't know, Green Lantern's
really like a title, so there have been a
bunch of people with that position, and
several others show up in this clip;
we'll get to them later. But before that,
look at the figure behind Flash. This
kind of looks like the comic version of
Darkseid. Now, he's the major villain
who's probably behind the conflict in
Justice League, and even if he doesn't
show up in the movie, Justice League, all
of these events are heading
towards a big showdown with Darkseid. So,
I'm predicting that we will see Green
Lantern and Darkseid appear in some form
in Justice League, either like a
surprise cameo during the movie or maybe
in a post-credits scene. Now, after
Justice League, the next movie on DC's
schedule is Aquaman, planned to release a
year later, in December 2018, and in
addition to Aquaman, over on the right is
his Queen, Mera, his brother and villain,
Ocean Master, and another Aquaman villain,
Black Manta.
Now, Mera will appear in Justice League,
she's played by Amber Heard, and Ocean
Master and Black Manta will be in an
Aquaman solo film, played by Patrick
Wilson and Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
Okay, another big film on DC's list is
The Batman, a solo Batman film starring Ben
Affleck. Now, Affleck originally wrote the
script and planned to direct, but he stepped
down and now Matt Reeves is taking over
as the director. It's scheduled to release
sometime in 2019. Now, remember Affleck
posted a picture a while back that teased
that Deathstroke will be in The Batman.
He's going to be played by Joe Manganiello and
Deathstroke actually shows up in this
intro - he's over here on the left. Now
other than Deathstroke being in it, we
don't know too much about The Batman, but
I could see a few of these other nearby
characters showing up in it. For example,
on the right you can see Harley Quinn
with her signature mallet and the Joker,
and even further down someone who looks
like Mr. Freeze. Now remember, there's
also a sequel to Suicide Squad that's
in the works, along with a Harley Quinn
spin-off movie called Gotham City Sirens
that's going to be directed by David
Ayer. That movie's rumored to have Harley
leading a group of female DC villains,
and one of those could be Catwoman, who
we see over here on the left, next to
Flash. It could also be fun to see
Catwoman showing up in The Batman, we'll
see. But one Batman character who's kind
of hard to see here is Nightwing. DC
actually announced that Dick Grayson -
Nightwing is getting his own solo film, too,
with Chris McKay attached to direct. He
directed the Lego Batman movie. Ok,
zooming out a bit here, some more
characters from upcoming DC movies start
to appear. There's Shazam and Black Adam
over by Catwoman and Deathstroke. Now Black
Adam is the antihero and arch-nemesis to
Captain Marvel, Shazam, who I think is the
figure next to Deathstroke, maybe this is
his alter ego, Billy Batson, who is also
visible in front of him, like he's in the
process of transforming into Captain
Marvel. Now, Black Adam will be played by
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson. He's actually
supposed to appear in Shazam, which he's
also producing, and that movie's
scheduled to come out April 2019.
Now, around this time, we're also supposed
to start seeing solo films for the Flash
and Cyborg, but both of those movies are
still very much in development, and I'm
guessing we'll know more about those
when we see how successful Justice
League ends up being. That goes for Justice
League, Part Two as well. We might
also see a sequel to Wonder Woman during
this time, but the studio is reportedly
still going over the details with Patty
Jenkins about that. But one thing that
does sound confirmed is that in 2020
there is another movie in the pipeline
Green Lantern Corps. I'm super excited
about this movie, especially after seeing
this intro, because so many of the Green
Lantern characters show up in it. Like,
besides Hal Jordan and John Stewart Green
Lanterns there's also the villains
Sinestro, Jessica Cruz, Kilowog and
Green Lantern Mogo, which is a sentient
living planet, which is why he's so
freaking huge here. Also this guy in
red looks like it could be Atrocitus.
He's another super villain from the
Green Lantern comics. He's also known as
the Red Lantern, and he's always like super
pissed off, so I'm really hoping that
this guy shows up in the Green Lantern
Corps movie. Now the last announced
upcoming DC movie that I'm excited about
is Batgirl, and that kind of looks like
her over on the left. Now, Batgirl is
going to be written and directed by Joss
Whedon. He's the genius behind the two
Avengers movies and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer.
Now, Joss Whedon has also apparently
taken over directing Justice League
while Zack Snyder takes some time off to
deal with a family tragedy. So yeah,
that's sad news for Snyder and we wish
him the best, but it's good to see that
the future of the DC movie universe is
in such good hands with Whedon in the
meantime. Okay I know this has already
been a ton of characters, but I'm going
to quickly run through and point out any
other possible sightings, and heads up,
some of these might be a bit obscure to
you. Okay, first there's an appearance by
original Justice League member, Martian
Manhunter - I think that's him standing
behind Harley Quinn. There's also a few
familiar heroes from the CW arrowverse -
there's Supergirl, Green Arrow, and maybe
Firestorm and Vixen over on the left
side. Now there aren't any firm plans to
bring these characters into the movies
yet, but we'll see. Like DC doesn't seem
to have an issue having two versions of
the Flash, so it's possible. Also on the
very far left, is the upcoming CW Hero,
Black Lightning. His solo TV series is set
to debut in 2018. Now, on both sides there
is Hawkgirl and Hawkman, both of whom
have appeared in different versions of
the Justice League comics or animated
series. And this bald guy to the right of
the Joker might be
Lex Luthor, which would make sense - they're
the arch enemies of Batman and Superman,
respectively. And the big guy behind
Nightwing looks like Swamp Thing. He has
one of the weirder origin stories in the DC
Comics, he's huge and made of plant
materials. Meanwhile another spooky
figure is over here, Solomon Grundy, a
villain who's a reanimated corpse. And
the little figure flying above him looks
like it could be Bumblebee, from Teen
Titans. Now, everyone else on the right
side is a little too tough to make out,
so for now let's pan back over to the
left. Now this massive looming figure,
based on its size at least, could be The
Spectre. He's a god-like, vengeful spirit
of police officer Jim Corrigan, but to be
honest, this is kind of a shot in the
dark. But in front of them look like a
few familiar faces from Suicide Squad.
I think that's Enchantress there, and then
Captain Boomerang, and that might be
Deadshot behind Batgirl there. And the
two flying figures up there could be Mr.
Miracle and Big Barda, they're a couple
and they're both New Gods with power
similar to that of Superman and Wonder
Woman. Now it's cool to be reminded that
DC has access to all these amazing
characters which makes me wonder, which
of these characters do you want to see
in their own solo films? Which ones do you
want to see in their own TV series? And
are there any that you just want to see
make little cameos in Justice League, Part Two? But another, deeper question: what do
you think are some other ways DC could
go other than following something close
to Marvel's universe-building model? Like, instead of these
Avengers-style team-up franchise movies
what if DC took a more Anthology
approach to these characters? Like, see
how Batgirl and Nightwing do in their
own solo films, where these heroes are
dealing with their own specific problems,
rather than worrying about the extended
universes. Like, I would love to see a
world where DC doesn't try to compete
with Marvel, and instead of world-building,
just give each of these amazing
characters their own, independent films
or short-run, standalone anthology series.
I want to know what you think. Comment
and let me know how you would tell
everyone at DC Warner Brothers how to do
their jobs. Who knows? Maybe they're
reading YouTube comments sections. Now I'm
determined to identify everyone in this
picture, and if you're with me on this
mission, please like this video and share
it around, let's get on this people. And
subscribe to new rockstars to see me and
others obsessively break down every other
DC property into its most interesting
missable details. And you could be more
part of our team here by contributing to
us on patreon. Thank you so much to all
of our
current donors, especially Kenny Smith. So
tweet at me with any other DC characters
that you spotted in this or any thoughts
you have about the DC movie universe can
also follow new rockstars on Twitter
(@newrockstars) for updates on our videos.
Ooh wait - I think I just spotted another
character... way in the corner there. Okay,
zoom in - oh my god, that's me! What the
hell? I'm a hero...